at this altitude I can run my hands this
episode is brought to you by Express VPN
I've been using expressvpn since last
summer and I started using it as a full
retail paying customer I always test
things before considering sponsors and I
find it to be a super reliable way to
make sure that my data are secure and
encrypted you liked how I said data are
like a pompous ass but I like to ensure
that my data are secure and encrypted
but to do so without slowing down my
internet speed if you ever use public
Wi-Fi let's say a hotel or coffee shop
where I often work and as many of my
listeners do you're often sending data
over an open network meaning no
encryption whatsoever one way to ensure
that all of your data are encrypted and
cannot be easily read by hackers or
script kiddies or whoever is by using
Express VPN and the onboarding process
for expressvpn meaning the signup flow
the use of the product is one of the
best I have ever seen in my life all you
need to do is download the Express VPN
app on your computer or smartphone and
then use the internet just as you
normally would you click one button in
the Express VPN app to secure 100% of
your network data it's kind of
ridiculously simple and as many of you
know I only recommend brands that I have
researched and vetted thoroughly for me
of the many VPN solutions out there
expressvpn is one of the best on the
market and I use it personally here a
few reasons why first privacy expressvpn
does not log your data lots of cheap or
free VPNs make money by selling your
data believe it or not to add companies
and so on expressvpn developed a
technology called trusted server to
prevent their servers from logging your
information second speed many VPN slow
your connection
or make your device seem sluggish just
to a crawl I've been using Express VPN
for a while now as I mentioned and my
internet speeds are blazingly fast I
don't even notice it honestly I forget
that it's even on so that includes when
I connect to servers thousands of miles
away or during travel I can still stream
HD quality videos with zero lag
the last thing that really sets
expressvpn apart is how easy it is to
use as I mentioned earlier
unlike other VPNs you don't have to
input or program anything you just start
up the app click one button and that's
it
super super simple and by the way it's
not just me saying all this about but
expressvpn you've got TechRadar the
verge CNET and many other publications
rating Express vpm as the number one VPN
in zippered so consider protecting
yourself with the VPN that I use and
trust use my link expressvpn dot-com /
Tim today and get an extra three months
free on a one-year package that's
expressvpn dot-com / Tim visit
expressvpn com / Tim to learn more this
episode is brought to you by LinkedIn
marketing solutions these days as you
know with a million messages per minute
not enough hours in the day how do you
really catch people's attention this is
where LinkedIn can help with LinkedIn
ads you can catch the right
professionals the right people at the
right time and I'll tell you how I'm
using them personally in a minute
LinkedIn ads can drive traffic to
landing pages for instance engagement
and for many of you most importantly
conversions whether that's registrations
for an event downloads of white papers
and ebooks or other important metrics me
personally I'm going to be testing
LinkedIn ads to drive signups to my free
newsletter 500 Friday which I've
realized drives just about everything
else with precise targeting through
LinkedIn entrepreneurs startups and SMB
sets small medium-sized businesses can
better and more cost effectively reach
the people who matter to them
specifically with more than 62 million
decision-makers on LinkedIn you're able
to connect with the business leaders or
just the target audience who are most
relevant to your company and deliver a
clear call-to-action
that's always where I focus a lot of my
energy obviously headline and
call-to-action LinkedIn ads allows you
to cut through the clutter and ensure
your messages are getting through to the
people you most want to target so huge
medium-sized and small businesses alike
are all making the most out of LinkedIn
ads entrepreneurs solopreneurs you name
it so try it for yourself
LinkedIn is offering a free $100
LinkedIn ad credit to launch your first
campaign simply visit linkedin.com slash
TFS as in Tim Ferriss show again that's
linkedin.com slash TFS terms and
conditions apply hello boys and girls
ladies and germs this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to a very special episode of the
Tim Ferriss show I have wanted to
interview this incredible guest since
day one of this podcast somewhere
between six and eight years ago and she
is a living legend dr. Jane Goodall she
was born on April 3rd 1934 in London
England at the young age of 26 she
followed her passion for animals in
Africa to gamba Tanzania where she began
her landmark study of chimpanzees in the
wild in herself like no one had before
in their habitat as a neighbor rather
than a distant observer her discovery in
1960 that chimpanzees not only used but
make tools rocked the scientific world
and redefined the relationship between
humans and animals in 1977 she
established the Jane Goodall Institute
JGI to advance her work around the world
and for generations to come
jagi continues the field research at
Gumby and builds on dr. goodall's
innovative approach to conservation
which recognizes the central role that
people play in the well-being of animals
and the environment in 1991 she founded
roots and shoots a global program that
empowers young people in nearly 60
countries and since its inception in
1991 has greatly impacted youth in more
than 100 countries to act as the
informed conservation leaders that the
world so urgently needs today dr.
Goodall travels around the world
normally 300 plus days here although
certainly quarantine changes that
speaking about the threats facing
chimpanzees environmental crises and her
reasons for hope and we do talk
quite a lot about our current situation
and I spoke to her from her childhood
home in England in her books and
speeches she emphasizes the
interconnectedness of all living things
and the collective power of individual
action dr. Goodall is a UN messenger of
peace and Dame commander of the British
Empire if that is not one of the coolest
titles you've ever heard I don't know
what is the next chapter of dr. Goodall
life's work unfolds in a brand-new
documentary and I highly highly
recommend watching it Jane Goodall the
hope premiering on Earth Day April 22nd
that's this April 22nd at 9:00 Eastern
8:00 central on Nat Geo Nat Geo Wild and
Nat Geo mundo the two-hour special takes
viewers through the chapters of her
amazing journey in the 60 years since
her groundbreaking discoveries in Gumby
research in wild chimpanzees including
her activism creation of a nonprofit
organization the Jane Goodall Institute
as I mentioned earlier jgi and roots and
shoots the youth program which you can
find out more about at roots and shoots
org along with her current efforts to
inspire the next generation
dr. Goodall has worked through the Jane
Goodall Institute is advanced to the
generous support of their donor family
people like you and me in other words to
show your support visit Jane Goodall dot
org forward slash Tim you can find her
on social on all social platforms at
Jane Goodall in Stan Institute at Jane
Goodall in style st and you can find out
more about her youth program and visit
them on social on all social platforms
at roots and shoots and without further
ado please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation that I so thoroughly
enjoyed myself with dr. Jane Goodall
dr. Goodall welcome to the show
thank you very much I'm thrilled to
finally connect I don't use the word
hero much but you've certainly been a
hero and an idol to me for many decades
in a previous lifetime I want to be a
marine biologist and I am also very
lucky in a sense that I have you in one
place because your team has told me that
you travel and have traveled 300 plus
days a year for the last several decades
but my understanding now is that you are
in Bournemouth and I thought we would
start perhaps close to the beginning and
this certainly takes place in England
just as context from your childhood I
understand that you grew up during
wartime and I would love to hear you
describe what that experience was like
well you know I'm really glad I grew up
at that time because although it was
shocking I mean we were in Bournemouth
but some bombs were dropped here that
the German fighters used to dump their
bombs near the coast if they hadn't
managed to hit the target and we're sort
of in the middle so we heard the bombs
falling we had sirens air-raid warnings
we had to go into an air-raid shelter
which was a little tiny cage really
supposed to be keeping people safe so
families with children were issued them
and people were killed and damaged and
we never knew where the bombs would fall
in London my uncle was a surgeon so he'd
come back every other weekend with
shocking tales of what had been
happening but the reason I say I was
glad I grew up then is because I learned
to take nothing for granted one square
of chocolate was a huge treat food was
rationed clothes were rationed we had
very little money there was no
television the only television were the
newsreels that was just about the war
and so books became very very important
and I still got my childhood books
they're here with me in the room as I
speak to you
and so we luckily had this garden it's
my grandmother's house and I spent lots
and lots of time out there with my dog
so the really shocking part was hearing
about the Holocaust and seeing
photographs of the skeletons of the Jews
when the camps were opened up
I mean skeletons of living people and
that really you know it changed
everything and I started thinking age 10
about good and evil
so that was my growing up in the war as
you were growing up I I read a number of
stories that seem to in a sense
foreshadow much of what would come later
but I read stories of your mother
finding you observing earthworms in your
bed I have read of stories of you hiding
and waiting for more than four hours to
see a hand laying an egg and the police
almost being called because you were
missing is is that comfort with patience
and on some level isolation something
that you developed yourself is that
something you've observed and other
family members I would love to hear you
comment on that if you could it was just
me I mean on the family you know loved
animals but they didn't observe them or
watch them I didn't have any any example
at all I was just born that way and was
having such a supportive mother I mean
both worms in my bed imagine all the
earth and the muck and lots of mothers
would have been horrified and and thrown
them out of the window but she just her
he quietly said you know they'll die
here and we took them back in the garden
and then the henhouse story it's one I
tell a lot because we went to stay on a
farm in the country and I was given the
job of collecting hens and it was a
proper farm there were no animals cooped
up in tiny prison lake quarters and
constant animal concentration camps
they were free roaming in the field and
the hens in the farmyard but they laid
their eggs in these little hen houses
and apparently I began asking everybody
but where does the egg come out nobody
told distinctly remember seeing this hen
go into a hen house and I crawled after
her and squawks of fear she flew out I
can still feel her wings hitting my face
and I must have thought in that little
four and a half year old brain
well no hen will lay an egg here it's
dangerous place so I waited that was the
time I waited and waited in this empty
her nerves but I was rewarded the hen
came in and I didn't know the family
being worried I was rushing towards the
house and there was mums you can imagine
how worried she was having nearly called
the police but instead of how dare you
go after and you dare do that again
should have killed the magic she sat
down to hear this amazing story and the
reason I love it is there's the making
of a little scientist curiosity asking
questions not getting the right answer
deciding to find out for yourself making
a mistake not giving up and learning
patience a different kind of mother
might have crushed that early scientific
curiosity and I might not have done what
I've done and it seemed to really
cultivate your not just ability but
perseverance with observation and in
watching footage of you and will
certainly get to Africa and other
experiences in your biography that you
have or appear to have many
sensitivities and I could be off base
with that but I want to ask you a bit
more about your mother because in
reading a New York Times profile from
suppose about a year ago there was a
one-paragraph that caught my eye and it
was related to your childhood during
wartime and related to your father's
brother Rex who had joined the airforce
and was killed and the sentence that
caught my eye was one day we were in
Bournemouth in the evening and
suddenly she your mother screamed rex
and started sobbing hysterically and it
was the very moment he was shot down
over Egypt
so just for clarity is that to say that
she somehow intuited that he had been
shot down before receiving news oh
absolutely I mean no we didn't know for
quite some time
we were walking on the beach and
normally we had to go up to our little
guest house
the quickest way but on this occasion
mum decided to take the long way which
she never did because she had a weak
heart but she took us too long when I
still remember looking up at the blue
blue sky and seeing an aeroplane quite
high I'm seeing two black things that
looked like cigars coming out on each
side and I'm true me and my sister to
the ground I can still hear the terrible
explosion and one of those bombs felt
right on the path where we would surely
have been if we gone this short way the
normal way have you experienced any of
that for lack of a better word intuition
in your own life in the field or
elsewhere or is that something that was
unique to your mother it was pretty
unique to her but you know I experienced
very vividly the presence of my second
husband after he died and it ties in
with what other people have seen and
felt so in other words we're going into
sort of a different realm here but you
know I don't know what people believe
and I'm not quite sure what it all means
myself but it's a people have been
asking me what's your next big adventure
and all we say dying because you know
when we die there's either nothing which
is fine or there's something and if
there's something what an adventure to
find out you've had you have had more
adventures than most and and I suppose
this is a good time for those who
certainly recognize your name I think
almost everyone will recognize your name
and they'll know that you're considered
to be one of the world's foremost
experts on chimpanzees but beyond that
I think many people don't know about the
early chapters and I'd like to segue to
that because it opens up a number of
doors that we can explore let's
flashback if we could to March 1957 and
I believe your passport is missing can
you explain what has happened and of
course in those days there weren't
planes going back and forth that's how
long I've lived and it was by boat and
we were actually I suppose a train a bus
or something I can't remember the
details and suddenly I found I didn't
have my passport and I remembered we'd
been shopping in Peter Jones and so mum
rang up shops that they'd found it we
found somebody to go and collect it who
rushed to the dock otherwise I couldn't
have sailed and all my money would have
been wasted so what a drama would a way
to start and that money just just for
those who aren't familiar that was
painstakingly gathered over a rather
long period of time with various jobs
was it not it's not like you had this in
a bank account just waiting to be used
for whatever purpose for a long period
of time when I left school there was no
money for university and I had to have a
job you know we had very little money so
I first of all did a secretarial course
which was boring but I got my diploma I
got a job then came the letter from a
school friend inviting me to Kenya so
you couldn't save money in London so I
went home and got a job as a waitress in
a hotel around a corner very hard work
in those days family is coming to spend
a week by the seaside and you got to
look after them for a whole week
if you wanted any son and the tips were
small but I made sure they all knew I
was saving up for Africa so that's how I
got the money I would love just to spend
a moment and we don't have to spend a
lot of time on this but discussing Louis
Leakey and I've read various accounts of
how you connected
with him but I'd like to hear it
directly from you and and perhaps you
could describe what it was that he saw
in you but that initial contact is and
how that came to be is is of great
interest to me so if you could speak to
that I would appreciate it okay well I'd
been staying with my friend for about I
suppose couple of months and somebody
said to me at a party if you're
interested in animals you really should
meet your sneaky
he was curator at that time at the
Natural History Museum but of course
he's best known as a very eminent
paleontologist
he spent his life with his second wife
Mary Leakey searching for the fossils of
Stone Age ancestors across Africa and so
I I was very shy back then but I rang
the museum and said I'd love to make an
appointment to meet dr. Leakey and I've
always said I'm Leakey what you want
anyway I was so passionate about animals
anyway went to see him and he took me
all around he asked me many questions
about the stuffed animals that were
there and I think he was impressed that
because I'd read everything I could
about Africa I could answer so many of
his questions well I mentioned earlier
that boring secretarial course that I
did two days before I met Leakey his
secretary had suddenly quit he needed a
secretary
and there I was you never know in this
life so I'm suddenly surrounded by
people who can answer all my questions
about the mammals and birds and the
reptiles the amphibians the insects the
plums it was heaven oh you are Leakey's
what did he see in me he feeling that
women made better observers he thought
they were more patient he also wanted
somebody to go and study chimpanzees
because of his interest in human
evolution so the fossils of early man
that he was uncover
you can tell a lot from a fossil but
whether the creature walked upright and
muscle attachments aware of the truth
shows you roughly the kind of diet but
behavior doesn't fossilize so he
reckoned there was a ape-like human-like
common ancestor about 6 million years
ago just now generally accepted and he
thought all of June Plains behavior and
chimps and humans today this is similar
or the same maybe it came directly from
the common ancestor and has been with us
through our long separate evolutionary
journeys in which case he could have a
better way of imagining how his early
humans used to behave so he wanted a
mind uncluttered by the reductionist
thinking of the animal behavior of
people at the time it was a very new
science they were anxious to make it a
hard science which it shouldn't be and
so the facts I hadn't been to college
was a plus and the fact that I was a
woman was a plus so I would just wish it
lucky well he he seems to have picked
the winning lottery ticket or at least a
very formidable combination of traits
and if we take that mention of patience
or his belief that in part women make
better observers because of more
patience if we flash forward then to you
landing in Gombe stream National Park
Tanzania from getting the pronunciation
correct I was watching the first Nat Geo
or maybe not the first but the the one
of the more recent Nat Geo documentary
is about you titled Jane and in that and
also in your writing I believe it took
something like five months of constant
effort and having chimpanzees flee from
your presence to finally be what we
might call accepted and I've two
questions related to that the first is
what do you think made the difference
why did they go from fleeing to
accepting
and second is when you first really had
the opportunity to look deeply into a
chimpanzees eyes what did you what did
you see and just as importantly what did
you feel all right well the acceptance
in the in the movie it sort of looked as
they suddenly accepted me and it wasn't
like that it was very gradual and it was
partly thanks to this one male who began
to lose his fear much ahead of the
others they called him David Greybeard
said a lovely white beard and because he
began to let me get closer and closer I
think if I came to a group in the forest
and he was with that group because they
separate into you know separate small
groups and sometimes alone but if he was
there then the others were ready to run
but he was sitting calmly and I suppose
that made them feel well she can't be so
dangerous after all so gradually I could
get closer and the first time I came
close to a group that didn't run away I
think was one of the proudest moments of
my life you know it made it just in time
for the six months money ran out and so
the the fact that I'd seen David
Greybeard use and make tools to fish for
termites thought to be something only
humans were capable of that's what
brought the geographic in right at the
beginning six months after the study
began and they agreed to go on funding
it it was David Greybeard the first
chimpanzee that you were able to get
close enough to to sort of connect I to
I with yes what did you see and feel
when you had that opportunity well I saw
that I was looking into the eyes of a
thinking feeling being and it was not so
surprising as you might think because I
had always felt that animals were
thinking feeling beings but with the
chimpanzee they're so like us
behaviorally and
biologically but it's it's almost it's
not like looking at another human it's
different and I can't explain how it's
different but it was a very magical
moment because he looked back that was
the thing he didn't run he just sat
there and looked back at me I would love
to ask questions about what we might
learn and what perhaps you've learned
about human nature or even questions
that have been raised in your
interactions and observations of
chimpanzees and you mentioned it briefly
but it's hard to overstate just how
incredible and shocking and
world-shattering for many people it was
that you observed chimpanzees not just
using tools but constructing tools for
in this case consuming termites I mean
it may it made news around the world you
had many other observations I believe
also that you know the belief that
chimpanzees were purely vegetarians also
you observed not to be the case with
their their consumption of other
primates exactly and you noted and I
know this was a real in some eyes a faux
pas at the time real personalities and
you might have been accused of
anthropomorphism and all of these things
but you observe different personalities
in different chimpanzees and I thought
perhaps we could just start with a story
and that is the story of old man and
Mark Kusano if I'm getting the
pronunciation right and then I have
questions about a few other chimpanzees
you personally had a quite a bit of
interaction with ok and old man this was
on an island in lion country safari in
Florida and old man had been in a
medical research lab he's been captured
from the wild his mother was shot and he
was called
man because an infant chimp who's
distressed and frightened they have
wrinkled faces and they huddle and they
do look very old and he was lucky it was
about 12 and for some reason he was
known no more used to the lab and he was
put on an island with three females two
of them from medical research one from a
circus and Mark Kusano is employed to
look after them and he was told don't go
anywhere any of them they're vicious
they hate people who might stronger than
you they'll kill you so he fruits food
from his little paddle boat onto the
island and began watching them and the
baby was born so old man was the father
and he felt you know these are such
amazing beings I must have some kind of
relationship with them if I'm to look
after them so began going closer and
closer on one day he held out a banana
in his hand that when when old man took
it he said I know how you felt when
David the banana from you one day he
went onto the island
one day he groomed old man one day that
they they played an old man laughed and
they became basically it was a
friendship and then one day marks lips
it had been raining fell flat on his
face
unfortunately frightened this infant who
was the love of old man's life the old
man used to protect him and carry him
and share food well the mother hearing
her child scream raced and attacked mark
biting into his neck the other two
females to support her ran in one bit
his wrist one bit his leg and mark
thought well how on earth am I going to
get away from them because I'm much
stronger than us he looked up he saw old
man thundering across the island with a
furious scowl on his face and he thought
his time had come to die I've come to
protect his precious infant but what old
man did was to pull those three
screaming Rose females off mark and keep
them away well
mark dragged himself to safety and I met
mark when he came out of hospital he
says no questions old man saved my life
and so you know I always think if a
chimpanzee who's been abused by people
can reach out to help a human friend in
time of need
then surely agree with our greater
capacity for compassion can do the same
to the chimpanzees in their time of need
thank you for telling that story and
it's I think a useful and beautiful
segue into a discussion of some of the
other things that you observed and in
this case we see compassion on the part
of old man and then perhaps on the other
hand you've also observed quite a lot of
aggression and violence within
chimpanzee communities the eve i think
it was 1974 278 Dombey chimpanzee war i
saw footage of i think it was the
southern troop being annihilated or at
least the the dead bodies of those
chimps i believe and please correct me
if i'm wrong that in some cases dominant
females will deliberately kill the young
of other females to maintain dominance
observing that in chimpanzees but also
observing the compassion as you have
what has that led you to believe or
infer about human nature
well it's interesting when I began
talking about that aggression many
scientists told me I should play that
down because it might indicate that
aggression in humans was inherited from
our past ancestors which for me was very
clearly the case and I thought well I'm
not going to be bullied and I never have
been by scientific opinion so I
continued to talk about it and it was
the time you wouldn't remember it was
1977 I think and it was a time when
whether aggression is innate inborn or
acquired learned
was it was a huge controversy and that's
when I first really talked about it to a
scientific community um and I I don't
know I mean it seems obvious to me that
we've inherited from our common ancestor
traits of aggression and also traits of
compassion and empathy to what extent if
we take an example from your personal
experience and and I I know very little
about Frodo but Frodo seems to have been
amongst the chimpanzees you had exposure
to one of the more aggressive but I'd
love to hear you speak to this and how
would you explain the variance among
chimpanzees was it also in appear to be
an 8 did it seem to stem from some type
of trauma how did you think about that
and perhaps Frodo specifically well
they're all different some are much more
aggressive than others just like we are
and Frodo was spoiled he was a spoiled
brat his mother was the highest ranking
female at the time Fifi he had to he had
one older brother who always came to his
defense as did Fifi and so he always got
his own way and he was he was a real
bully so it's there were two young ones
playing same age as him perhaps and he
came to join them they would stop
playing immediately because they knew if
he entered the game he'd suddenly become
rough and cause one of them to be hurt
so it wasn't just humans field
assistants and especially me but he
targeted with his displays hitting over
dragging oh I got it worst of all I was
stamped upon them but he was not trying
really to hurt me he was trying to
assert his dominance and I guess they
don't realize quite how strong they are
I mean if he wanted to kill me I
wouldn't be speaking to you now that's
for sure is
is the assertion of dominance does it's
and I don't know how much of this is
conscious and I don't know how one would
even know but is is that is that a a
conscious or potentially conscious
political maneuver to to get better
access to resources and so on or is it
really just a conditioned behavior based
on as you said being being spoiled and
that just being some type of primitive
drive that they have and perhaps even we
have Frodo's brother before him became
the top ranking male and Freud had a
very different character he was
reflective he became dominant not
through aggression but through being
smart some of the males get to the top
by sheer aggression by bullying by
swaggering about waving their arms they
remind me so much of some human
politicians it's not true but there are
other males who get to the top by
skillfully forming alliances and they
only tackle a high-ranking male when
their Ally is there to support them and
then there are some who just persist
they persist in charging towards groups
of superior males who are grooming each
other startling them so they run away
and in the end this was Goblin pinion I
think the other males thought well he's
just going to go on doing this alright
let's just let him get to the top we
don't care anymore
it's that that's how it seemed and he
and he was small and he wasn't very
aggressive at all you are I think for
many people a messenger of hope and I
personally swing quite often more often
than I would like between having faith
in humankind human nature and feeling as
though we are perhaps hard-coded or
through DNA destined to at times revert
to our
less ourselves lowest selves most
aggressive selfish selves how have you
formed your own thinking or I should say
what is this what is your thinking about
human nature and where it has led us and
how that relates to perhaps poor
decisions and good decisions that we've
made that have landed us where we are
certainly you're in your childhood home
spending more time in England now than
you have in decades
I'm also in in lockdown but how after
your many decades of observation of not
just chimpanzees but humans where do
where do you currently stand on thinking
about human nature well I find that
there are some people who really cost a
very bad light on human beings if we
look down from another planet and that's
I mean you know as I told you earlier I
was so shocked about the Holocaust and
that's what made me think about human
evil and the way we differ from the
chimps is that chimps can be aggressive
and chimps can kill but it's on it it's
something that's roused in them it's a
strong emotion and they just display an
attack but human beings can sit and
think and plan deliberate torture mental
and physical in cold blood and that I
think is where we differ and it changes
from aggression to evil and it's a
dichotomy I mean some people are saintly
and patient and do good and other people
the opposite and unfortunately today we
have many presidents and prime ministers
who seem to be more concerned for their
own advancement their own careers their
own power their own acquisition of
wealth than for the good of the people
who elected them so we're both and it's
going to be a race isn't it as to which
side will win and if the
the greedy materialism of the capitalist
materialistic world wins then we're
doomed and this is why I spend so much
of my time trying to grow our program
for young people because I would say
almost none of the young people who've
been through this program which began in
91 and is now in six countries and his
kindergarten through University and I
don't I don't know of more than two
who've strayed from the path of having
good values respect for nature respect
for each other so I want to grow more
and more of these young people because
they're the future and we've been
stealing their future for decades and
this is the roots and shoots youth
program that you're referring to
yes roots and shoots org I'll also put
that in the show notes for everyone of
course let's let's talk a little bit
more about that and as it relates to
youth program the the cultivation of
minds that are inclined to bend towards
the light instead of the darkness or
towards good instead of evil I know
those are very strong words but let's
use them for now if we're looking at the
the current situation as it relates to
SARS cough - and Cove in nineteen and so
on could you speak to what got us into
this fix and I mean I'm thinking of
course the wildlife trade its effects on
human health and so on doesn't need to
be specific to that but how we got here
how we contributed to it and then also
if if you're teaching youth how you
would how you would educate them so that
they don't make the same mistakes I did
it's a bit of a sloppy question sorry
about that
with the hope it 19 because that's on
everybody's minds right now and the
shocking thing is it's been predicted by
and for decades just like climate change
has been predicted and I only wish that
somehow they've been locked down about
climate change the way that there's
being locked down over this over the
spread of this virus because you know we
we we have known for all this time
but because we are destroying the
environment of some of these animals
they're spending they're having to spend
more time in contact with each other
because they've got less habitat and
also more time in contact with humans
and sometimes that's it that involves
crop raiding but there's also people
penetrating deeper and hunting and then
of course selling the meat in the
African markets bush meat and then
selling meat across Asia and he's
terrible what they're known as wet
markets and also selling animals for
medication for pets all of this bringing
us in close contact so the theory seems
to be that there's a virus in a wild
animal and because of this closer
contact between animals it jumps into
another animal and that's when in these
very bad conditions including factory
farms by the way the virus can then jump
into a human if there is a similar kind
of virus with which this new one can
bind and that leads to a new new form
which as is the case with with Kovach 19
can be rather devastating but just think
if we if we treated climate change like
this all those years ago and we were
warned about it we might not be in the
state we're in now so basically what I'm
saying is our leaders have not listened
to science the big corporations have not
listened to science and hundreds of
people now we're in this materialistic
money-grabbing age you know just want to
carry on with business
usually they don't want to think about
not eating all the meat they want or not
favoring the destruction of a piece of
habitat to build yet another shopping
mall so you know that's that's what this
virus is teaching us and will we learn
from it we didn't seem to learn from
SARS the markets were live animals were
banned for a while but then it started
up again China is now talking about
making it permanent but they're still
allowing animals wild animals to be sold
for medicine so that's a tremendous
loophole luckily people in China want to
close that loophole too and if you have
a classroom and as you do now with
social media I mean you you are arguably
reaching more people now virtually then
you might in travel speaking to live
audiences but let's just say you had a
classroom of 10,000 children or
adolescents youth who were hanging on
your every word what are the these sort
of principles or truths that you would
infuse in your lessons to them that
could possibly help avoid some of these
problems that we've we've created or
types of thinking what would the what
would the curriculum look like well let
me just say that roots and treats which
began in 1991 twelve high school
students in Daraa Salaam in Tanzania we
decided at a meeting because they were
worried about you know poaching in the
parks and illegal dynamite fishing and
street children and cruel treatment of
animals in the market I mean they were
concerned about all kinds of different
things so we decided that the main
message of this new program that we
wanted to start together would be that
every single individual matters is a
role to play and makes a difference
every single day with a choice as to
what kind of difference to make right
from the beginning because I learned
about the indica neck
things in the rainforest how every
species matters and has a role to play
we decided that every group formed would
choose between them three projects one
to help people want to help animals one
to help the environment and they would
share their projects with each other and
so we began listening to them what did
they feel mattered how could we help
them and when when young people
understand the problems and we empower
them to take action and listen to their
voices it's quite extraordinary I mean
the main reason for hope is traveling
around the world as I have been I've met
so many young people they've been part
of roots and shoots or similar groups
shining eyes wanting to tell dr. Jain
what they've been doing to make this a
better world because they can choose
they they they're passionate and they
sit down together and they discuss it
it's very democratic they discuss what
what they can do between them they
sometimes ask for help maybe a parent
maybe a teacher and then they roll up
their sleeves and take action whether
it's restoring a wetland whether it's
installing rubbish bins or organic
gardens in the schools whether it's
saving up money to help earthquake
victims and because we put them in touch
with each other face to face when
possible but virtually which is
wonderful they are inspiring each other
yes we do have some curricula because
some countries wanted UK wanted a
curricula so we're in a hundred and one
thousand seven hundred schools now and
some of the African countries want
curricula sometimes it's just you know
so yes I do have messages for them and I
do talk to them but the role that they
can play about the importance of
thinking about the consequences of the
little choices you may
each day how people may look different
sound different of a different language
a different color of skin but if they
fall and bleed the blood is the same if
they weep the tears are the same and
kids get it so it's not so much teaching
it's it's sort of the values have
developed they've grown up with the
program and we now have a number of
adults in quite high places and they
have kept their values as they as they
read the program and move on into adult
life so we've got teachers and people in
government and people in law and they're
just remembering the importance of
respect it's a key word respect the
environment respect for animals and of
course I tell them about animals and how
each one has a personality a mind and
emotion have pigs and rats and octopus
are amazingly intelligent and how they
can feel pain and fear and despair so it
depends on their children on their age
it's kindergarten University everything
in between depends what I tell them but
I do as many gatherings of young people
as I possibly can and as you say now I
can do it virtually and I can talk to
them about things that I've learned I
recall a few years ago speaking with a
friend of mine who I considered to be a
good father a good parent and I asked
him what advice you would have for
someone like me considering having
children I have none of my own yet and
his advice he had a number of pieces of
advice but his first was teach your
children to be optimists and it seemed
like a precursor or a prerequisite for
so many other things and I'm looking at
a time article Time magazine article
that is that you wrote in 2002 and I
just want to read one paragraph and then
ask you to elaborate or speak to it so
here's the paragraph
the greatest danger to our future is
apathy we cannot expect those living in
poverty and ignorance to worry about
saving the world for those of us able to
read this magazine and my side note or
listen to this podcast it is different
we can do something to preserve our
planet you may be overcome however by
feelings of helplessness you are just
one person in a world of six billion
how can your actions make a difference
best you say to leave it to decision
makers and so you do nothing can we
overcome apathy yes but only if we have
hope and at left ear you speak to that
and also just to how you cultivate hope
whether that's in yourself or the people
you speak to well you know I have my
reasons for hope which I'm always
sharing with people but this thing of
people feeling helpless because they
don't know what to do this message of
our youth program that every individual
makes a difference and you know if it's
just you picking up trash if it's just
you saving water then it wouldn't make
the slightest bit of difference but
because people are becoming more aware
all around the world then there's no not
just you but thousands millions of
people picking up trash and saving water
and so the message again being think
about the consequences of the small
choices you make every day what do you
eat where did it come from the baton the
environment was it crawled to animals
like the intensive bombing is it cheap
because of child slave labor somewhere
make ethical choices and because
millions of people are making ethical
choices we're moving in the right
direction and all of our young people
you know they're influencing their
parents and their grandparents I know
that because the parents tell me so you
know my reasons for hope number one is
the youth as I've said because they're
just so inspiring and secondly it to
start by saying it's very bizarre but
what makes us more different from chimps
and other animals is
explosive development about intellect I
mean look at what's happening now with
just social media it's one example you
and I talking went far apart we're
reaching millions of people a minute
it's quite amazing isn't it when you
think about it we've sent rockets to
Mars and all that sort of thing so how
odd that this most intellectual creature
is destroying its only home so that
seems to be this disconnect between the
clever brain and the human heart which
is love and compassion and you know
we're thinking about how does this help
me now instead of how does it affect
future generations so now we're
beginning to use our brains or
scientists are to come up with more and
more sophisticated technology that will
help us lead better living more harmony
with the natural world
if governments would sponsor clean green
energy rather than their succumbing to
their ties with the oil and gas industry
we could be more or less off the grid in
many countries today China and India are
moving in that direction rapidly and UAE
as well but each one of us can use our
brains to think about the the
environmental footprint we make each day
remembers the resilience of nature I
tell people's stories about areas that
were totally destroyed rivers lakes Lake
Erie was so polluted but it's that it
caught fire was so polluted and now this
fish swimming in it because people cared
animals on the brink of extinction are
being given another chance we just have
to save the habitats we have to change
the mindset of those companies that want
to destroy forests to make money out of
the wood or destroy forest to get
minerals out of the ground to make mom
more money but then we've got to some of
poverty because as you quoted earlier if
you're really poor what what can what
can you
except cut the last tree down you're
desperate to grow food to feed your
family eat the cheapest junk food
because you've got to do it to live so
we have to solve property and the
unsustainable lifestyle of the rest of
us but you know my last reason to hope
is this indomitable human spirit the
people who have tackled what seems
impossible and won't give up and they
may die as a result of their conviction
but in the end they succeed I would love
to speak about the power of storytelling
we've we've been discussing for least a
few minutes or at least made mention of
intellect and technology too powerful
and very interrelated facets of our
human experience in watching the trailer
for perhaps the next chapter of your
life's work that will be shown and the
story told in jane goodall the hope
which is going to premiere on Earth Day
April 22nd on NatGeo
and I'll include that geo wild and Nat
Geo mundo I'll include all of those
details in the show notes and also will
have already mentioned them in the
introduction but there was a there was a
quote in that trailer about changing
minds and that the quote is this if you
want somebody to change their mind it's
no good arguing you've got to reach the
heart and I wanted to this might seem
like a strange segue I'd love to ask the
question of mr. McGregor and and how he
came to his end could you speak to who
mr. McGregor was and ultimately how he
died mr. McGregor was an old male even
when I first got to come be slightly
bald on the top of his head bit
cantankerous and he was just really very
very special and he had a special
relationship with a young female I don't
know if she was related to him but he
was old and she was young
to protect her and then probably the
darkest days even worse than the war was
when the chimps were affected with a
polio epidemic and it was a terrible
time first one would come back dragging
a paralyzed limb one male learned to
walk upright because one arm totally
paralyzed but mr. McGregor was paralyzed
in both legs and he dragged himself up
to the feeding station and I think the
most awful part was that the other
chimpanzees shunned him a fear of
strangeness which of course is very
adaptive if it's an infectious disease
but I can never forget there was a group
of the other males grooming in a tree
and with enormous effort Gregor dragged
himself from branch to branch with just
the strength of his arms and they took
one look and climbed down and the look
on his face all this effort what have I
done wrong why are they going away and
very slowly he drew he he went down to
the ground again and in the end we had
to shoot him because we didn't have any
other way of euthanizing him we could
have kept him alive feeding him bananas
but if you'd seen the sadness on his
face there was no way that was a life
for a chimpanzee it would have been
cruel so it made a deep deep impression
on me mr. McGregor and when I saw it in
the movie they brought I brought it all
back it was a terrible time what did you
take from that experience whether mr.
McGregor and that entire experience or
the polio itself affecting the
chimpanzees around you what did you what
did you take from that experience or
learn from that experience
well and they definitely caught it from
human beings fortunately none of us none
of us at all but there was an epidemic
in the nearby town and for some odd
reason the doctor said it wasn't polio
no what he thought it was so there was
no medication there was no vaccination
and the first blame chimps seen way down
south near that place and I presume that
it spread from them up to our community
because there was nobody in our star for
betting anybody who got polio what did I
take away from it
the fact that you know I think human
beings have tended to treat people who
behave strangely with fear and shun them
that's led to a lot of suffering like
people with cerebral palsy people used
to shut them away not realizing that
inside all those strange movements and
sometimes strange sounds inside is a is
a perfectly normal brain but that brain
can't express itself so mr. McGregor had
a what we think was his younger brother
and country was the only one who never
left he wouldn't go near Gregor but he
stayed nearby in the trees even when all
the rest of the group went far away
feeding on some fruit comfrey stayed and
after week we'd euthanized like we did
it when no chimps were around including
Humphrey for at least the next month
Humphrey came and sat in trees near
where mr. McGregor had been so it just
taught me a lot about how chimpanzees
and humans react to something strange if
we then look at the work you're doing
now the work you've been doing over the
last several decades but particularly
with the the youth program and
also in my mind trying to affect change
with decision-makers the the people in
positions of power who are responding to
their own incentives whether that be
could be getting reelected it could be
power of some other type it could be
acquisition of of capital could be any
number of things are there any stories
that you have found particularly
effective for reaching the heart to grab
the attention of of people as you've
traveled and spoken with so many over so
many so many decades is there anything
that sticks out to you well you're
absolutely right telling stories I
always try and spend a little bit of
time finding out the person I'm going to
meet if it's somebody you know in
government of something do they have
children do they have dogs I mean you
know just so you can start something
often not just I'm here for this blah
blah blah lobbying on the hill for
example and then try to tell stories
because I've found that if you point
fingers if you're argumentative if
you're blaming then you don't you don't
see change because they're not going to
let especially a woman some high-powered
man there's nothing to let a woman make
him look stupid by saying oh you're
right and I'm wrong change I believe has
to come from within and so if you can
reach the heart and there was a medical
research lab and I managed to get better
conditions in that lab by reaching the
heart of the director of the lab telling
stories about the chimps and there was
another director of a lab and this is
slightly different but he had a 16 year
old daughter who came to one of my
lectures and I was showing secretly
filmed footage of the awful conditions
in the lab of which he was director
conditions for the chimps he said his
daughter came back one day from this
lecture
sobbing I'm saying daddy you're so cruel
how can you do this
and he said Jane for two years I
absolutely hated you but he said please
could you come and see the lab now
because you were right and I never
accused him directly it was through his
daughter and he changed the lab
completely and then the last story I
love I was in a taxi it was very early
in the morning I was very tired I was
going to have a snooze on the way to the
airport and Oh he'd heard that I was one
of those animal lovers and oh he
couldn't stand that and his sister was
one of those animal lovers too and
through all these poor people
why won't be helping them what was it
about animals so I thought oh well
that's the end of my snooze and I pulled
open the window lean forward and in the
jump seat and I told him stories about
the chimps and stories about dogs all
the way to the airport when we got there
and he just grunted and you know I
thought well it didn't make any
difference but I had to try he owed me
10 pounds at the end because he didn't
have any change so I said we'll give it
to your sister for the work she does in
the shelter animal shelter I never
thought he would but I got back two
weeks later there was a letter from the
sister and she said first of all I
really want to thank you for your
donation but secondly what did you do to
my brother she said he's listening to me
he's been three times to help me in the
shelter so it's always worth doing your
best because you never know what in fact
that is going to have sometimes you will
never know it was pure luck
but that ended the way it did that's
incredible and if we if we dig into that
just a little bit more whether it's that
first director of the lab or the cab
driver
you mentioned telling stories about the
chimps but there are many different ways
to tell stories and there are many
stories that could be told what types of
stories
did you tell either of them that you
think could have had that impact
oh well I talked about the very strong
bonds between family members
the maternal behavior I told stories
like when one infant lost his mother he
was three years old
job well done he didn't have an older
brother or sister who would have adopted
him because that's what they do
and he was adopted by a 12 year old
unrelated adolescent male who carried
him around who shared his food with him
drew him into the night nurse and they
slept curled up together and most
amazingly an adolescent male usually
keep well out of the way about all males
when they're or they're socially roused
and charging about screaming but little
male who normally would have been taken
away by his mother before it got into
danger and spindle risk everything by
running in to rescue him if he got too
close to those males even though he was
beaten up quite badly himself because he
was a the adolescent males the
scapegoats for the big males and he
saved Mills life without any question
though that's the kind of story that I
turn on you also seem to be aside from
an expert storyteller very good at using
imagery or symbols and sometimes stories
themselves are symbols but could you
describe mr. H who's mr. H mr. H was
given to me 28 years ago by a man called
Gary Horne which is why he's mr. H Gary
went blind when he was 21 decided to
become a magician everybody said but
Gary you can't be a magician if you're
blind he did those shows for children I
watched him three or four times now and
of course he sets his props up ahead of
time children don't know he's blind and
at the end he'll tell them and he'll
say you know something might go wrong in
your life you can't tell if it does
don't give up this always away forward
and he does scuba dive in cross-country
skiing skydiving but I think most
amazing he's taught himself to paint and
when he gave me mr. age he thought he
was giving me a stuffed chimp but mr.
age has a tail and I made him hold the
tail he said never mind take him with
you and you know I'm with you in spirit
so he's one of those examples of the
indomitable human spirit doing skydiving
when you're blind teaching yourself to
paint and there's a picture in this he's
done a little book called blind artist
which you can only get on Amazon and the
third portrait of mr. age he's never
seen him he's only felt him and it's
unbelievable and mr. H if I'm not
mistaken has been many places with you
is he I don't know if you still have mr.
H but I forget take him to a lecture
sure to be a child who bursts into tears
that I wanted to touch mr. H because I
tell them the inspiration rubs off but
you know I have other symbols I have one
of the long long long I think of I'm
trying to major with my uh my hands over
two foot feather from the wing of a
California condor I've got all the
proper permits for it and they were they
were down to 12 Birds and now there's
very many of them flying the skies and
so I have that as a symbol of the fact
we can save animals from extinction I've
got a piece of the Berlin Wall there was
a time after the war when we thought
that that Berlin Wall was up forever
between East and West Germany but it
came down wolves do come down despite
what one of our country's presidents
thinks about wolves
and so I carry these little symbols with
me I've got a piece of limestone from
the quarry where Nelson Mandela labored
for 21 years I think was 21 years in the
limestone quarry
before he attained his freedom and moved
his country out of the evil regime of
apartheid do you still have Jubilee and
could you explain who Jubilee is Jubilee
you know so many people think that
because my father gave me a very large
stop chimpanzee when I was 1 and a half
but that is why I chose to study
chimpanzees it couldn't be further from
the truth
but I did love Jubilee and Jubilee I had
when I was one and a half and I'm 60 I
mean 86 now so you can imagine he's
nearly bored now and he's actually
sitting in the National Geographic
exhibition in DC in a specially built
bulletproof glass case because I didn't
want him you know I thought it's
dangerous for him to go away he's much
too precious but he was hand carried and
he's sitting down that exhibition is
going to go online they've made it some
way of showing it to people so people
will be able to see the real Jubilee in
that in that it's called becoming Jane
so Jubilee went with me everywhere when
I was a child I mean literally
everywhere and when you then had your
own child after your experiences with
your mother my understanding is that you
didn't have much of a relationship with
your father but more so with your mother
and then your experiences with the
chimpanzee mother's flow for instance
how did you think about mothering or
parenting imagine a lot of it was a very
primal
drive that was created in you but what
did you decide were there any decisions
based on what your mother did with you
or what you observed in Flo and others
that affected your parenting style or
mothering style yeah well you know who
he over baby type really was when when I
was pregnant I thought about mothering
and I was in Africa I thought about the
way mum raised me I got dr. Spock was
all the rage then and actually he has
some really sound advice but I also
thought about Flo I had all those three
examples along with as you say our sort
of instinct because after the baby was
born of course I adored him and hidden a
film Jane I'd forgotten what a gorgeous
baby he was actually enchanting anyway
so what I learned from the chimp mothers
is just like us there are good and bad
mothers and the good chin mothers are
like mine they support their child even
if they know they're going to get
attacked they will run to rescue their
child from danger and the offspring of
those now we can look back and find that
they tend to do better they more
assertive more confident the male's
reach a higher position in the hierarchy
probably saw more offspring and females
are better mothers but the one thing
that I really took away from from Flo
and the other chimp mothers they love to
play with their babies they would spend
hours playing with them and I thought
yes I'm gonna have fun with my baby too
a lot of things that chimp mothers did
you know lying on my back and sort of
dangling grub from my feet and tickling
him and things like that so I had a lot
of fun with him and that chamber
merchants how did he get the name grub
it was very silly he was born about the
same time as a little chimp called
Goblin
and goblin was a very messy eater I mean
all the other chimps would tumble around
playing and come out sleek and black and
he had he'd have every bird around stuck
to his his hair and one case he got hold
of a very big banana it was but as big
as him
and he's eating it but you know he eats
far too much so he takes a mouthful
large mouthful
he spits it into his hand he looks at it
and then he smashes the hand with the
banana over his face my son he was a
messy eater too he didn't want to be
weaned and he didn't like baby food and
he would do much like goblin he was a
complete mess with it
and so it became goblin the chimp goblin
grub and then my son became grumbling
gob his real name is probably nickname
and in in the in the film Jane I'm
referring to for people listening and we
don't have to spend a ton of time on
this if you prefer to discuss other
things but I found myself wandering
after grub was really raised in the bush
and had this natural existence at some
point the decision was made to help him
socialize and be educated and I remember
the footage in this film of walking down
the street hand in hand in London what
was it like for him going from these all
natural environments to that urban
environment and being dropped off at
school and just supposed the time after
that that he was dropped off well you
know he was quite a bit at the time not
in the bush he was in Nairobi and he did
go to school there so it wasn't that you
and also my mother had been out visiting
twice so he knew her very very well and
when he went back to England he wasn't
just dumped in the school he went to
live where I am now in this house I'm
actually in this very room and so he was
with an extended family and he loved
actually loved school
so you know it wasn't it's sort of
sounds brutal but it was more brutal for
me than him because he enjoyed school
and I felt that I shouldn't have let him
go but I wouldn't have mom and the
family hadn't been there she was in a
very loving home and it wasn't really
that strange how do you relate to being
alone it seems that you're very
comfortable incredibly comfortable
spending time solitary by yourself
certainly in in Africa that seemed to be
the case how do you relate to that I
think that that being alone is something
many people fear how do you think about
it and relate to it well you know when a
child I was spending hours alone out
with the birds and watching insects with
my dog going up and down the cliffs of
Bournemouth which was actually really
good training for Bombay it's not that
different and I used to spend hours up
in the top of my favorite tree which I'm
looking at right now Beach is a beech
tree and I felt you know up near the
birds and closer I don't know it was a
wonderful feeling being alone being
alone out in the forest in Gombe
absolute bliss and the biggest problem
with my life on the road is that I have
so little time alone so hotel rooms come
to be a sort of haven in a way because I
can shut and lock the door I'm alone and
do you find that you recharge by
yourself or what what is what is your
experience like by yourself I know that
might sound like a strange question but
many people busy themselves to avoid
being alone or feeling alone what what
what does it feel like for you to be
alone just feels really peacefully it
means that I can think my own thoughts I
can do things like reading and I think
being a child growing up with no TV you
know reading reading is much less busy
than watching a TV show and I think it's
very sad that so many children
don't get to read more and have all this
television all the time you know I was
in love with Tarzan and when Mum saved
up to take me to probably the first
Johnny Weissmuller film that came over
great treat for James took me and after
a little while I started to cry and she
had to take me out she had whatever the
matter I said but that wasn't Tarzan
because there was no TV and no movies I
had my own Tarzan that I fell in love
with and it wasn't Johnny wise have that
opportunity anymore because right from
the beginning their deluge dwith with
some information of how they should see
the world you you strike me as someone
with not just unique perspectives on the
world but a unique capability in sharing
them through not not just storytelling
and sheer endurance but also a high
degree of compassion and that this is
all a way of leading up to a question
related to something you mentioned
earlier and that is you just a handful
of days ago really turn to 86 and you
see him as sharp as ever as busy as ever
someone on your team was saying that you
their impression is that you seem to
work from 6:00 a.m. to 10:00 p.m. with
the exception of a dog walk in the
middle - what do you attribute you the
maintenance or maybe even increase of
your mental clarity and sharpness and
endurance for such a long period of time
well first of all I obviously inherited
very good genes from my father actually
that was a major contribution he made to
Who I am a lot of the rest of it came
from but he had he was tough and strong
he could endure so he was in the war
anyway what do I attribute it all to
well I don't actually think people say
do you have do you exercise do you
meditate
what what food what diet and on and on
like that what supplements and I say
well I you know I just eat what's around
I don't want to eat very much I don't
care about food I don't take any
supplements I don't have a special diet
except I'm vegetarian or when I'm at
home now
vegan and I don't have time to do
exercise usually it's been just the
airports my walking with the dog now yes
but he's old and he's the only dog I've
ever met who doesn't like walking and
even when he was you to say he didn't
he's a whippet it's more like a cat
morning honestly it was like taking a
reluctant snail out for a walk it's
because well I mean if you think about
things and I've always loved writing I
think that's very important I didn't
want to be a scientist I wanted to be a
naturalist live with animals and write
books about them and so I've always
loved writing my mother loved writing to
write I have a story somewhere I can't
find it now but I dictated it to her
when I was five and it was a charming
little story but of giraffe with the
neck that was so long he could reach up
to the moon yeah so it was always
animals you see so telling stories
thinking about stories that used to
write a lot of poetry and it's just you
know if I'd known when I was younger
what going to study chimps wouldn't be
mad I'd be having this life and become
thanks to Geographic really becoming a
sort of icon when it first happened I
was really really disturbed because you
know why were people thinking about me
like that I was just me it was a lucky
person but then I realize well if people
against recognized me because of
Geographic and and come up and want a
signature of selfie now
then I must make use of it and be nice
to them and smile at them and give them
a brochure and tell him about roots and
shoots so there was a time when as I
went around the u.s. you could see the
roots and shoots group springing up in
front like a comment with a tail but
obviously it was a look back on my life
honestly Tim and I see that there were
stages and at the end of his stage there
was a crossroads and it never seemed
that I consciously made a decision it
just was something that happened to
change me and I think I've made the
right decisions and I meant to be here
and I meant to be doing this
that gives me extra I suppose endurance
to cope with it and I care passionately
about the future for the environment
animals and children and suppose because
I think a lot I gained wisdom I hope and
I want to share it well I think you're
doing a a fantastic beyond fantastic job
and one thing I've also noticed and
gathered from people who work with you
on your team and seen certainly in
videos is that people many fans of yours
many people you you encounter become
very emotional in your presence they
might break down and tears for instance
that is not always the case with figures
who are well known how would you explain
that or why do you why do you think
that's the case that so many people get
so emotional when they meet you and they
don't seem to know and then apologize I
say no no don't apologize it's it's
something that for some odd reason I
inspire these tears I asked them why
they why they're crying and they say
well I never thought I'd see you I can't
believe I'm seeing you I'm so happy to
be to be here and you've made my dream
come true
and I suppose
I don't know my grandmother used to cry
every time she was happy it seems like
that seems like you make a lot of people
happy and perhaps it is I mean as a
messenger of hope in many respects that
you give people hope I think that
there's in some respects a real shortage
of hope in many people's minds and I'm
giving the gloom and doom and there's a
hell of a lot of gloom and doom I know
but there's also such wonderful things
happening and sharing the good stories
the successes the nobility of so many
people the self-sacrifice which we're
seeing with the coronavirus to then then
people realize all is not lost
there's still a lot that we can do to
make this a better world and after
lectures as always at least one and
often more people who come up and say I
had lost hope but I promise you I'm
going to do my bit thank you for giving
me some hope again well I think this job
of mine of giving people hope is a
really important one right now right now
more than ever before and it's so
compelling I think not just because you
are good at giving people hope but also
because you are in a way living proof
and the poster child for what hope can
enable you to do if that makes any sense
you're not just a passive commentator
giving lip service to hope I mean you
are a case study in how much fuel and
endurance in part hope can provide I
think that's at least for me why it's so
compelling and convincing and and
inspiring so thank you for that you said
that your friend told you to teach your
children to be to be optimistic it's
it's really fun teach them that but you
can tell stories and tell stories about
people and encourage them and support
them I mean so many parents have set
views on what they want their child to
be and the
they get from my mother is it was nobody
was thinking about going to Africa
living with animals when I wanted to
except a few explorers you know we
wanted to shoot them and twickum in
museums but when everybody laughed at me
and said I'd never get there I was just
a girl it was a war we didn't have money
mom said if you really want something
like this you're going to have to work
really really hard but take advantage of
every opportunity and if you don't give
up you'll find a way to do some do that
or something something else that you
really really want to do and that story
I that wisdom I take and share with
young people everywhere especially in
disadvantaged communities and I wish mom
knew how many people have said Jane
thank you you taught me that because you
did it I can do it too you have so many
projects and opportunities ahead of you
before I perhaps tie this to a close
with a description of a few things that
you have coming and then tell people
where they can find out more about you
and certainly follow along with your
continued adventures I'd be curious to
ask if you had a billboard
metaphorically speaking that could get a
message out to billions of people it
could be a word a phrase a question and
image really anything what might you put
on that billboard that you hmm
perfect that could not be could not be
more perfect dr. Jane Goodall you have a
new documentary this is certainly
continuing to showcase the incredible
work you do this is Jane Goodall
subtitle the Hope which is premiering on
Earth Day
that's this April 22nd 90 stores and not
geo mundo it is a two-hour documentary
special that will take viewers through
chapters
of your journey in the sixty years since
your groundbreaking discoveries in Gumby
researching wild chimpanzees including
your activism creation of your nonprofit
organization and where and also where
people can find more about you Jane
Goodall org that is the Jane Goodall
Institute
JGI and Roots & Shoots roots institutes
dot org
that is your youth program along with
your current efforts to inspire the next
generation and I would go I step further
and say not just efforts but successes
it's it's tremendously inspiring not
just not just because of the ethos but
the actual effect that you are having
it's just remarkable people can find you
on social media you're also doing some
very fun things like story time with dr.
Jane but Instagram that is at Jane
Goodall Institute I on st twitter jane
goodall in stand same on facebook jane
goodall in stand then the roots and
shoots is the same on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter the handle is at roots and
shoots this has been such a tremendous
honor and pleasure for me to spend so
much time with you I appreciate your
generosity in granting the interview
providing time and also really keeping
up the good fight and being a purveyor
and spreader of hope in a world where it
is so easy to succumb to despair and
hopelessness it's it's just tremendous
it's it's really a gift that you are
providing so I hope that that you're
able to fuel that and let that sink in
at times but I appreciate you so much
for taking the time to chat with me
today well I want to thank you too
giving me the chance to chat to you I
get interviewed by lots and lots of
people sometimes a bit boring but I
haven't been a tool bored talking to you
so thank you to that really means so
much and please keep it up I will do my
best to get your message your work this
interview to many millions of people who
hopefully will intern
share it and spread it because I think
that that hope really is the foundation
here upon which so much else depends and
for everyone listening I will have
everything in the show notes links to
everything we discussed at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and dr. jane
goodall thank you so much and I hope we
get to meet in person someday hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn marketing solutions these days
as you know the million messages per
minute not enough hours in the day how
do you really catch people's attention
this is where LinkedIn can help with
LinkedIn ads you can catch the right
professionals the right people at the
right time and I'll tell you how I'm
using them personally in a minute
LinkedIn ads can drive traffic to
landing pages for instance engagement
and for many of you most importantly
conversions whether that's registrations
for an event downloads of white papers
and ebooks or other important metrics me
personally I'm going to be testing
LinkedIn ads to drive signups to my free
newsletter 500 Friday which I have real
drives just about everything else with
precise targeting through LinkedIn
entrepreneurs startups and SMBs its
small medium-sized businesses can better
and more cost effectively reach the
people who matter to them specifically
with more than 62 million
decision-makers on LinkedIn you're able
to connect with the business leaders or
just the target audience who are most
relevant to your company and deliver a
clear call-to-action that's always where
I focus a lot of my energy obviously
headline and call to action LinkedIn ads
allows you to cut through the clutter
and ensure your messages are getting
through to the people you most want to
target so huge medium-sized and small
businesses alike are all making the most
out of LinkedIn ads entrepreneurs
solopreneurs you name it so try it for
yourself LinkedIn is offering a free
$100 LinkedIn ad credit to launch your
first campaign simply visit linkedin.com
slash TFS as in Tim Ferriss show again
that's linkedin.com slash TFS terms and
conditions apply this episode is brought
to you by expressvpn I've been using
crest VPN since last summer and I
started using it as a full retail paying
customer I always test things before
considering sponsors and I find it to be
a super reliable way to make sure that
my data are secure and encrypted you
liked how I said data are like a pompous
ass but I like to ensure that my data
are secure and encrypted but to do so
without slowing down my internet speed
if you ever use public Wi-Fi that's a
hotel or coffee shop where I often work
and as many of my listeners do you're
often sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption whatsoever one way
to ensure than all of your data are
encrypt
and cannot be easily read by hackers or
script kiddies or whoever is by using
expressvpn and the onboarding process
for expressvpn meaning the signup flow
or the use of the product is one of the
best I have ever seen in my life
all you need to do is download the
expressvpn app on your computer or
smartphone and then use the internet
just as you normally would you click one
button in the expressvpn app and secure
100% of your network data it's kind of
ridiculously simple and as many of you
know I only recommend brands that I have
researched and vetted thoroughly for me
of the many VPN solutions out there
expressvpn is one of the best on the
market and I use it personally here are
a few reasons why first privacy first
VPN does not log your data lots of cheap
or free VPNs make money by selling your
data believe it or not to add companies
and so on expressvpn developed
technology called trusted server to
prevent their servers from logging your
information second speed many VPNs slow
your connection down or make your device
seems sluggish just to a crawl I've been
using expressvpn for a while now as I
mentioned and my internet speeds are
blazingly fast I don't even notice it
honestly I forget that it's even on so
that includes when I connect to servers
thousands of miles away or during travel
I can still stream HD quality videos
with zero lag the last thing that really
sets expressvpn apart is how easy it is
to use as I mentioned earlier
unlike other VPNs you don't have to
input a program anything you just start
up the app click one button and that's
it super super simple
and by the way it's not just me saying
all this about that expressvpn you've
got TechRadar the verge CNET and many
other publications rating Express BPM as
the number one began in
there so consider protecting yourself
with the VPN than I use and trust use my
link expressvpn comm / Tim today and get
an extra three months free on a one-year
package that's expressvpn comm / Tim
visit expressvpn comm / Tim to learn
more
you
you
you